[Music]
let's go to kerry in des moines in des
moines what's up
hi how are you i'm rocking on how are
you
good what's up okay so um i am calling
for some guidance i guess um in relation
to my my kids um about nine months ago i
found out that my husband was having an
affair with my best friend oh
i no it's horrible um she actually also
used to work at our church um so there's
like a whole thing why not face concept
yeah right right you got one more what
else
i know uh yes let me tell you did you
keep your kids too on the weekends
probably who nick cheese louise i'm so
sorry dude yes no worse no you're right
there oh
why not
i'm so sorry
yeah me too
but
our divorce was very quick
the other side's divorce
definitely is taking longer
but my concern is the kids throughout
all of this i've tried very very hard to
you know keep them out of the middle of
it
and i will fully admit that i've made
mistakes but
i think um i'm learning that my
ex-husband
is a narcissist which is very hard for
me to admit um but now that that control
is off of me
um i feel like it's on to the kids and i
don't
i'm just really struggling with how to
how to best parent them by myself
um knowing that
we split our time 50 50. and it's just
it's just brutal and and i don't know
what to do
yeah so number one
absolutely who cares about the other
divorce
i don't care about it i don't want to
know about it i'm not gonna do i'm not
gonna talk to anybody but anybody brings
it up i'm gonna stop and say i don't
care i don't wanna talk about it okay
you shouldn't know when that thing's
final how about that
okay that's how far away i want you from
that it doesn't matter
she is not your concern and not your
life
if she chooses to be in relationship
continuing relationship with your with
your ex-husband and y'all get they get
married or something like that then
there will be some very hard adult
conversations that have to happen
because she will be conversations
between adults no you and her and you
and your ex because she's going to be in
proximity hanging out with your children
that's already happening okay so there
needs to be some very clear not yet
there needs to be some very clear
conversations with her i mean with you
and your ex
okay about your expectations about how
the relationship with your kids
be careful about lobbing diagnostics
meaning i don't care if your husband's a
diagnosed diagnosed narcissist i care
how he treats you
sure and one would impact the other but
right now that diagnostic doesn't matter
what matters is if my husband is lying
to my children if he's not showing up if
he's blaming them for things taking
their money if he's doing things like
that
um using power to coerce them into doing
things things that narcissists do
then i'm going to deal with the
behaviors i'm not going to point back to
the diagnostics does that make sense
sure yeah absolutely so for example he
um has blocked certain people from my
daughter's phone um that he pays for uh
and they happen to be my friends just
because he doesn't think that they're
good people or something um
he's their dad and when she's on his
property he's allowed to do that
you can get him a different phone it's
still his daughter's phone
right okay all right now when she comes
back to your house she can have a
separate phone if you want to do that
you don't have to do that that's what
i'm saying it's a pain
um or
you can um
you can have your friends over when your
kids are over and you can just they can
have human conversations right so all to
say is yeah he can do that if that's
that's the game he wants to play so be
it
okay okay
and hey here's the thing
nothing is good moving forward here
oh that's encouraging
i mean this is all sifting through the
ashes of a burned down home to try to
find pictures that you can still see
exactly right and then you got to build
something new
and so how do i do that well it's not
this is nine months away your whole
world blew up
yeah no
and you haven't stopped and grieved this
thing
nope yes
you have to
no i don't want to i know i know but
here's the thing okay
how many kids you got
two how old are they
11 and 8.
so
you are a powder keg of hurt right now
and you are strong as bloody hell right
yup yup
and you
have taken out a bunch of plywood even
though it's super expensive at the store
right now and you have
bolted that pain down
inside your chest and that's where it
goes
yep and it still puts off heat
yep and your kids are getting burned
yeah yes
and here's the problem they think it's
their fault
yes they do
and they don't deserve that
nope they don't you don't either
i know i don't but i care more about
them it doesn't matter the best way to
care about them is to care about you
and if you don't deal with that that
that nuclear reactor in there
it will leak out all over your insides
you're gonna end up with all kind of
weird stuff
okay okay
so okay gotta deal with it the greatest
gift you can give your kids
is to let them see you be sad
and heartbroken and devastated and still
in control of yourself
and to see you have friends come over
and take them out because mommy's heard
it all those things
yeah because right now they feel the gap
they feel the tension they feel dad's
rage they feel that's her in this and
they drop off and on and they're
wondering what did we do
sure
my eight-year-old
keeps saying
if if i do have sad moments or or hard
times
he will frequently say
it's over
mom the big d that's what he calls it
the big d is over yeah um and that's
hard too because i'm like no it's not
honey we we're gonna live with this
forever yeah um
and so just
i don't know i don't know how to help
them right
i think it's teaching them
that the
it's a great moment for gift like grief
goes on for a while
yeah pain hurts and loss hurts and this
is what it looks like
and so there is ways to be honest and
when they run into life life hits them
in the mouth which it will
and none of us want that for our kids
but it will and for them it already has
right
right but when it does again they will
have a picture
of oh
that's what grief looks like and this is
a healthy way to deal with this thing
and healthy looks like sometimes crying
so hard i can't breathe
sometimes it looks like mom goes and
sees a counselor
okay
because hey you had plans
you had pictures of what thanksgiving
was gonna look like when your
son had brought home whoever
yep exactly and it's all different now
you got to grieve the picture
but they're they're hurting so much
yes
yes
i feel like i have to focus on them like
i'm fine you're not you're not
you got double betrayed the person you
would have called to tell them that your
husband cheated on you was the other
woman
yep
you are correct
that is scorched earth
i'm talking to somebody who i think is
still in shock
and you sprinted so fast through the
divorce
to get that thing done
yep
honey there's a wrecking coming for you
and it's best if you have it on your own
terms
what does that mean that means your
body's gonna shut you down soon
oh
okay okay
it will start looking like anxiety it
will start looking like rage it will
start looking like anger it will look
like trust issues it will look like i
can't sleep
oh i i've already had all of that oh not
have you'll you'll
it'll be present i'm not saying this to
scare you i'm saying you're worth being
well
sure
and that means i got to sit in this for
a season
okay let me just
do you think you can just move on
just go i i don't but i feel like i have
dealt with some of it um yeah sure i
totally still have trust issues and the
waves of this whole thing are insane i
go from anger to to just sad to okay i'm
good too okay all right so you are
you're working through it you are you
are i am i truly believe that i am yeah
okay all right you are okay so i i take
this i'm also i'm also uh
very stubborn and refuse to let this
affect my kids so i will do whatever i
have to do and go through whatever hell
i have to go through
um in order for my kids to come out of
this okay and so that's that's yes i'm
dealing with myself i have an immense
amount of friends who are incredibly
great christian women um
your husband dragged your kids through
hell
and i'm mad
you should be you should be raged out
mad
you're trying to protect him from
something that's already happened to him
yeah
but it's still happening that's what i'm
struggling with it's going in the middle
it's going to because your husband knows
what happened
and the moment this new person moves in
there's going to be a new stark reality
because he's got his new person and he
went with him
and he went and he went with him
oh yeah
he more than likely did not like who he
had become in relationship with you
yeah
i yeah
but dude do you really have to sleep
with my butt i mean i mean like he
absolutely didn't nope didn't at all
didn't at all
and so now my kids too are seeing oh
that's mom's best friend who who used to
be super involved in our church and work
at the church and now this is what's
happening have you have you sat down
with your kids and said mommy's best
friend really hurt mom and so we are not
friends anymore okay absolutely okay
yep and so the best they can in their 11
year old little hearts and minds and
their eight-year-old hearts and minds
that we're gonna have that conversation
and i'm gonna i'm not gonna bring that
person up anymore
oh and i would say things like i prefer
to not talk about her right now thank
you
okay
okay you don't have to engage every one
of these conversations
okay the conversations about um i'm not
safe or i'm being hurt or those are
absolutely we're gonna have those
conversations
okay
and when your kids get to be middle
schoolers and they start to try to
weaponize all this because their pain is
just bizarre and strange like like a
like a bouncy ball inside their chest
and they're trying to figure it all out
they will be like well she lets us fill
in the blank
and you will have to
swallow your soul and go
yeah she does but here at my house we
don't do that
sure
and that would be hard
right mm-hmm
yeah but i'm not gonna i haven't really
thought of the whole don't engage thing
so i like that
yeah now listen you don't want your kids
feel like they're on an island
oh no i know that's also a concern of
mine yes yeah
they can come to you anything i don't
i'd choose to have a conversation about
her right now thank you so much for for
bringing that to me or are you safe
yeah sure great cool
yeah
now my eight-year-old has kind of
changed to um saying frequently that no
one likes him that everyone hates him
and so i give him as much reassurance as
possible but that's really draining as
well as well as the emotional drops that
they
that's what i call them when they when
they come back from dad's house like all
these emotions are just dumped right at
my house and we go through this
roller coaster of crazy um but
do you have any suggestions on that
um your son is
that's shame
shame that is this pain inside your son
saying what did i do
okay okay okay and
fewer words more touching
okay fewer words more just sitting down
watching a show together and snuggling
up
okay and making sure he's got purpose
and role in your in your home
okay a lot of times there's guilt from
parents i don't want them to feel like
they got to come here and do chores or i
don't feel like they need a role they
need participation i went through that
okay i definitely went through that so
now i'm trying to re-implement that um
because i learned that that was not a
good way to handle it okay so bring him
along you want to give him a good gift
go to michael's or go to uh hobby lobby
i just talked about this on the last
call get a big
36 inch um canvas art canvas and get
some paints or whatever and it's going
to look ridiculous unless you're one of
those pinterest moms and if you are
congratulations and
you all decide
we're we are creating new family values
here what is that going to look like and
order their favorite foods and you all
have a fun night doing it and you know
write it down on a piece of paper and
then you paint it all together and you
hang in your living room
and this becomes a touch point that they
got to participate in because they
matter
oh i like that okay
they're they've right now they feel
completely powerless and it's just a
bunch of hurt and they have these
fantasies that y'all gonna get back
together and we'll figure this whole
thing out and we'll just get back to
quote-unquote normal
and then the big d happened like okay
it's already happened so it's over but
there's still the fantasy
and
that's gonna be another level of
devastation if you or your husband gets
remarried all that stuff will is part of
this process there's no way to shelter
them from that pain what you can do is
give them a foundation that they can
absorb that pain from
oh i like that okay okay
okay
you are playing a really really long
game here a long game you're pay playing
a
25 21
18 they look back and say my mom's
my mom loved us through through
a mess
mom walked alongside us mom brought us
into this deal and um i had a role at
mom's house
and
giving a kid
seeing a kid giving them value and
giving them purpose
that goes a long way kids are really
resilient when they have those three
things